today we're unboxing the new Nintendo
switch lights I'm a little bit late to
the unboxing and checking this out
because I was out of town this past
weekend so I didn't get a chance to get
it on release date but I am so excited
because I travel a lot and I always have
my switch with me so anything that could
maybe make that travelling experience a
little bit easier with a little bit
smaller of a console I am so into a huge
thank-you notes Hendo for sending me one
of these to check out I was so excited
because ever since they announced this I
was like okay cool a small em tend to
switch in fun colors yes please
so this is the turquoise version it also
comes in yellow and a gray I love this
color this looks so great let's open it
up and check it out oh yeah okay okay
alright this already feels better mostly
just because it feels like it's all one
piece which it is but here it is like
look I love this color this is pretty
minimalist like all you have is a
charger and the console the main
question that I think a lot of people
are asking themselves is do I need a
Nintendo switch light which Nintendo
switch should I get this feels like a
replacement for the 3ds for the 2d s if
you ever plan on playing on your TV if
you want to dock this this one is not
dockable this is solely for portable
gaming if you already have a Nintendo
switch and you also want to have any
tendus which is light you can still use
the light version with your other
Nintendo switch but I think it gets a
little bit complicated with the cloud
saving because you have to set want to
give Nintendo switches as a primary
Nintendo switch and one is the secondary
I'm not sure if there's an easy way to
do that yet I haven't tried it out yet
these are only from articles and reviews
that I've read so
I don't know hundred percent no so this
also doesn't have a kickstand so this is
something that really is made for just
handheld play you can connect joy Kahn's
if you want to play in tabletop mode so
that is also an option but again if you
do want to be able to play on your
television this is not the switch for
you you would have to get either the
launch version or Ravine you to Tendo
switch now the difference between the
new Nintendo switch is it does have a
little bit faster but processor and the
battery life and a little better than
the launch version the antenna switch
light battery is about the equivalent of
the original Nintendo switch but the new
Nintendo switch has a better battery
life than this one and the launch
Nintendo's just any of this make sense
it's really not that complicated but I
feel like as I'm saying these words
everything just sounds very difficult
either way let me break this down for
you do you want to only be able to play
on the go and save $100 get the switch
light do you want to be able to dock
your Nintendo switch and be able to take
it on the go
then get the Nintendo switch and pay an
extra hundred dollars it's kind of crazy
that this is only like $200 like you're
getting an incredibly powerful machine
in the palm of both of your hands I feel
like the nitendo switch is probably
gonna be due for a larger upgrade
sometime in the near future since I
guess the original one came out and 2017
so that's great
oh hello so the screen is a little bit
smaller than the previous version of
addition to switch but because the
screen is smaller the pixel density
makes it seem like the screen is a
little more crisp so that is something
that you should notice okay we're
successfully connected will I remember
my password four minutes into account
probably not we import user data okay do
you still have the console yes a system
update is required okay you do that
so we're gonna go to system settings
we're gonna update this then we're gonna
transfer everything over this antenna
switch tonight we have been through so
much together we have been around the
world and back again so you can
definitely tell the size difference it's
basically like if you took off one of
the joy con control
so that's about the size Nintendo also
sent a legend of zelda links awakening
I'm so excited because I have a bunch of
travel coming up so this is gonna be so
perfect I love mobile gaming I know that
we're talking about Nintendo with even
having the Apple arcade has been amazing
just because no matter where I am and I
want to play a game to pass in time have
games in the palm of my hand this is
cool I'm gonna need to get a Nintendo
switch case now if you guys have any
recommendations for some carrying cases
let me know are you restarting now this
does look pretty good I like that has a
full d-pad whereas this one they have to
kind of make the little buttons so it's
like a fake d-pad since the Joye cons
are so interchangeable downloadable
software purchased by the transferred
user who Nolan Weaver on the tar gun huh
we've been keeping the previous console
in addition to this one yes ok so let's
get this all set up might transfer over
all of my data from this switch to this
switch and then it all should be well a
few moments later ok guys that was
actually a lot easier than I thought
right now I've got Tetris installing and
I ended up doing the digital download of
zelda links awakening because for some
reason i just prefer having it as
digital as opposed to a cartridge that
means i'm gonna maybe give this as a
gift to Jenna Jenna can you come here
real quick
remember we played this at 3 that's
awakening she's a big smile on her face
ok here you go
Jenna doesn't wanna be seen careful
what's downloading its downloading
careful careful no that's my phone did
you just leave it there it's actually
freaking I was hurt
Oh games we have on here what have I
been playing overcooked love Mario
Tennis asus mario party i'm like our
diablo oh what a great game
super mario brothers just lux got Tetris
like a movie mortal kombat mario maker
well thank you guys for watching I look
forward to testing this out a little bit
more and also finding a nice case for it
let me see
Amazon let's see what we have for a
Nintendo switch light cases this is the
case that I have been using for the
regular inattentive switch this was
honestly something I just found on
Amazon and I'd loved it because it's
such a small profile
I just put my fingers in there come a
little extras here of course my Zelda
precious precious precious so it looks
like they have where this is like the
same exact case but for this which light
thank you I will take it
count me in I would put a link in the
description if you want to check it out
I mean it's nothing fancy it's just
exactly what I need you know what I also
wanted to get wireless Bluetooth
transmitter it was 12 South I believe so
it looks like there's a couple of them
let's see here I think it was 12 cells
that had one so this one's a bestseller
so I'm gonna go with this one if we're
gonna try this out and see how it's the
next day my Amazon orders have already
arrived so I got my case and then the
little Bluetooth adapter this carrying
case looks perfect
it's basically the same exact case that
I had before but smaller and that's the
unboxing of the case let's see what it
looks like in here looks just like my
other case but smaller a little place
for cartridges and just pry put some
headphones or something here that's a
good little spot to put this welcome to
a life with better sound
your accessories here what are you I
haven't seen you since 1990 got a lot of
things here if you guys missed the memo
this basically will turn anything that
you have with a 3.5 millimeter headphone
jack into bluetooth pairing when powered
on press the power button twice to start
pairing just got these new set new
headphones
very nice well I'm glad these are noise
cancelling look how cool I'm gonna be
come on Bluetooth is connected can you
hear that notice that in my head oh my
gosh this sounds so good why have I not
got one of these sooner how long about a
switch this is incredible
well see you guys in my next video thank
you so much for watching let me know
what games you guys are playing on your
Nintendo switches or if you have a 3d or
2d yes I would love to hear what you
guys aren't looking forward to most I
cannot wait for the Wii Gees mansion and
I definitely pre-ordering it looks like
it's coming out on Halloween which is so
perfect until then I'll see you guys
later
[Music]